Một quay nào vàng á đưa ra những tưởng thật tránh yệu về tỉnh hình giao tránh tại Minorat.
Thì tránh năm phía đông Pro Cross, hú đô thuy này được xem là một tiêu trên lược trong chứ dứt của ngà,
giám kiểm soát tòn bộ vùng đối nhất.
Thế có đổ ua quay nào, các đơn vị của họ, ở bận dữ vững vị chỉ và tư dịch lượng trên đón,
ở các hướng tiếp tận Minorat, trong thời đại lơn trên bì c bị thương và đưa tiếp đề vào thị tránh,
dụt tình hình hậu cần rất khó khăn.
Tổng thống của lối đi Miyazinski cho biết,
đơn vị ua quay nào đang trụ vững quayng Pro Cross và đô Pro Pilia,
nơi kia khẳng định đã đạt đúng mơ sâu kia trên thật.
Nước lại bố phòng ngà từ bố trên telegram rằng,
được lượng nước này đang áp xa Minorat và đã dành được quên kìm sốt hà cù vực của Thì tránh.
Ngà cũng khẳng định chiếm băng ngưu làng dọc trên tuyện dài một miếng tuyên mát,
trong đó có hàng ngưu làng ở tình ra porizia,
tổng tư lệ lượng vũa ngùa quay nào ở nha lịch dạng đời,
tổng tư lệ lắm chắc bức tên của đối phân.
Kèo chuyên chàng đi state theo dõi trên sử mạnh của ngờ,
đi ban Phu Croc hiện này chủ yêu với lập phòng giám tất chờ bên nào,
kìm sốt dõi dàng.